if someone else can run paid ads in your
industry you can run paid ads in your
industry it's just a skill and guess how
they learned it trial and error I've
been doing this a long time and it's
still sometime takes 3 months 6 months
to get it to really crank all the way
through from click all the way to the
close because each time you have to fix
some little element of it until all of a
sudden it will click and then it will
Skyrocket and that's usually how it is
so you basically like lose money lose
money lose money lose money and then it
crushes and then you figure it out and I
really think it's the expectation that
it's going to happen overnight that
kills way more people who would
otherwise be exceptional advertisers